dans la famille boots il y à la fille au
violon le fils à la trompette et la mer
au piano moi parce que j'aime maurice
andré vous et du coup je choisisse à ce
que j'aime bien moi je sais plus comment
j'ai toujours aimé le piano donc j'ai
appris le piano
ben moi d'abord puisque je trouve que je
vais l'ont devancé c'est une belle
sonorité et puis je trouvais que la
façon dont tenue larcher il est du coup
j'ai voulu faire ça parce que je
trouvais que j'avais une belle tenue
ils se préparent pour la quatrième
édition du concert des familles
le conservatoire de plaisir en lien avec
les réseaux des maisons de familles de
la ville réunit fratrie et par an sur
scène j'ai repris maintenant
les dernières pour pouvoir essayer d'en
refaire avec un essai de la soutenir et
puis bah puisque je trouve ça sympa de
pouvoir jouer du piano avec ma fille
grâce à lui je ferais continuer le piano
encore très longtemps
j'aime bien jouer du piano avec mon papa
[Musique]
un piano pour quatre frères et soeurs
une vingtaine de familles s'est inscrite
pour jouir à la maison des familles
flora tristan déjà ça nous permet aussi
de voir un peu de promotion de 80
familles qu'on peut gens sauront
s'entendre que c'est pas comme l'écrit
jean fait des frères et soeurs qui passe
temps se discuter et tout est là en fait
c'est là où on fait tourner une urne et
une seule personne en fait les
professeurs sont mobilise pour préparer
avec eux les morceaux en s'adaptant à
tous les niveaux des débutants aux plus
confirmés
c'est ton premier morceau j'ai eu peur
j'ai la trouille
ils pourront tous compter sur leurs
familles pour les soutenir et affronter
le trac de jeunes artistes qu'il soit
dans le public ou sur scène
[Musique]